salut romain ça va bien les vacances on
n'a pas le temps salut et oui pour nous
aussi c'est la rentrée bon après ttc ne
s'est pas arrêté cet été mais je suis
quand même parti un petit peu en
vacances comme en témoigne ce comptage
ce qu'on a vu alors qu'il rentrait dix
vidéos de rentrée l'année dernière j'ai
eu 90 ans le temps d'une journée j'ai
flotté tout nu dans le noir je me suis
mis en slip par -150 degrés je me suis
fait tatouer la fesse je me suis fait
des tatoués la presse enfin et j'ai
transformé romain en pénis tu le fais
hyper bien bref on a testé plein de
trucs et on a très envie de continuer
alors si vous avez des idées si vous
avez envie que je teste quelque chose en
particulier
dites le dans les commentaires
l'année dernière j'ai aussi rencontré
plein de gens très cool qui avait plein
de choses très intéressantes à raconter
et là encore ça va continuer et là
encore si vous avez des idées
l'année dernière on a aussi parlé de
plein de sujets très différents
je suis allée des conventions où j'ai
rencontré certaines et certains d'entre
eux est notamment très très récemment au
festival frames à avignon c'était génial
vous m'avez donné plein d'idées pour la
nouvelle saison on va essayer de faire
encore mieux que les précédentes donc
cette année en plus des formats que vous
connaissez déjà on va essayer de
développer des nouveaux formats et vous
avez sûrement aussi pouvoir me voir en
dehors de détester mais ça me prend par
l'épaule donc vous ai compris la saison
3 de dtc ça sera plus que jamais avec
vous donc là chez vous dans les
commentaires dites moi tout ce qui vous
a plu dans les précédentes tout ce qui
vous a pas plu tout ce que vous avez
envie de voir dans la nouvelle
on se retrouve dès la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo elle est déjà
tournée elle est formidable
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien ça va être ce prix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]